i as a layperson i think that my
takeaway
so far my my
general sense
is that
ufos this whole thing
is a good thing because they don't want
us to blow up the world with nuclear
weapons well people want that to be the
case
i wish that was the case the evidence
doesn't suggest that's the case
i think ufos don't want us getting too
powerful i don't think that
because you won't just look at the
nuclear weapons you got to go back
thousands of years and go in the
earliest documentations of mankind's
encounters with the spirit world
what was happening just macro brush
stroke okay and it's always about
managing suppressing consciousness
confusing our belief systems
and and keeping us separate from one
another and not letting us get powerful
you know there was another component of
the uh
the that pleiadian
theory which was that
and by the way i think it was like 300
000 years ago they said that they
unplugged the dna um there was another
piece to it which was that the the
entities that unplugged us
were uh
nourished
not by physical matter but nourished by
emotion yeah they actually uh were there
there's their sustenance was and and
specifically fear yes so fear
feeds this this entity that that
controls us and so it's in their
interest that we be afraid yeah there's
a i was just reading a book in osango
where there's a ufologist that got
invited to this seance thing where they
were channeling and interacting with
this like [ __ ] demon or something
and they're all sitting in a circle and
then they put the one guy in the middle
and he starts channeling and gets
possessed by the sentencing the first
entities like hey we're
where are we are these entities that are
adjacent to you in another timeline
and all this stuff and we can't feel
emotion and but we need you to host to
help us feel emotion but then [ __ ]
starts going horribly wrong paranormal
stuff the temperature drops all this
weird [ __ ] and everyone in that room
except for two people died within six
months and weird occurrences
and this guy was one of the guys that
didn't and what i find is really strange
about that is that when you
you know
having a host consciousness in your body
um and then
looking at some of the visitations and
what some of the evidence looks like it
looks like there's
there's beings that don't have
it's like maybe they don't have souls
maybe they're ai maybe they're a
different life form like an insect that
grew it's like well i'm not scared of a
goldfish so i leave earth i come back 10
billion years later that goldfish is a
t-rex and you're like whoa and then you
leave earth and then you'll go that
t-rex is now like a lot shorter and it's
like a [ __ ] lizard dude that's
telepathic and building spaceships and
you're like it took like 20 billion
years but it happened because no one
[ __ ] [ __ ] with this planet you know
right so you can see how life just grows
in a certain direction so then you kind
of wonder well if something grew for
millions billions of years that never
had a consciousness to begin with like a
fly
or something and then
now it can kind of pop over laterally
and to our [ __ ] timeline it's going
to come on you like flies on dog [ __ ] oh
what is this huh what is this they're
just like looking at you right how scary
would that be if in your bed and you got
these big bug-eyed insects they're like
what are you what is going on they start
cutting you open and they're like and
then i'll send you get scared like
that's an interesting energy there i'll
feel that we can feel something you know
i can see that being the case where
emotion and feeling
and love is like so gnarly it's like
they want to understand it they want to
have it but what if they figure out like
hypothetically what if they figure out
that um
that we're immortal
that our soul
is part of something greater and bigger
right and we might die and have a
painful life but we learn a lot of
lessons we might reincarnate
you know to learn more whatever and
they're sitting here going if we die we
have nothing
they're all we want that
and then what if we have those
interactions we start writing books in
the bible it says satan wants your soul
demons want your soul
you know it starts to all make a little
bit more sense right
it's a crazy bigger picture it's just me
briffing i'm not saying anything
it's me riffing so is that what they're
doing when they're like abducting people
like that the fire in the sky movie the
evidence
from people that have had interactions
for
[ __ ] thousands of years including the
past hundred years on all different
types of people ethnicities and
different [ __ ] cultures and different
continents
tends to point the same direction that
they're very interested in our
consciousness and our soul and they're
very interested in making sure that we
don't know they're here and that we
don't all align and understand who we
are what we're capable of and like
because the truth is is once we
understand what consciousness is
and it's not jesus
you know once we understand that then we
start realizing you can move objects
with your mind you can hear people's
thoughts telepathically like if you meet
a chick and she wants to [ __ ] you that's
telepathy but it's such a primal
animal frequency you can feel it wow
this chick's like game right but if you
see that same chick and she's sad you
don't really feel that just instantly
you might kind of it's just not as
strong and easy as like a sexual kind of
frequency or something well that's all
telepathy and i think like once we learn
like what we're capable of and how to
use
how to how to
transduce our environment i mean because
they're already doing this dude i just
downloaded a [ __ ] ton of documents
two days ago
from the mcdonald douglas corporation
aircrafts in the 50s
and it's all from the tangential
programs of the main ufo program
describing
how to merge your conscious and
subconscious together to move objects
with your mind and how that's going to
relate to the propulsion system
it's [ __ ] crazy your thought will
move the craft
so that's what bob lazar was talking
about how they're
building the the crafts
the reason we all know about area 51 is
because of him my company to the stars
put out his autobiography it's called
dreamland it's rad yeah it's totally rad
yeah and i i i believe them i think it's
telling the truth when when you say that
they're worried
they're they're
the ufos don't want
humans to become too powerful
like and i think there's more than one
too like i don't think there's like
one group here so it's hard we all agree
it's like it's like when we it would be
more better to say ufos it's probably
better to say you know competing
intelligences because who knows it's
like you're in the ocean you see a
dolphin so you're like okay so this
place is full of dolphins and you see a
[ __ ] jellyfish you're like oh that's
weird you see a whale but then you see a
coke can
and you're like
then you find the boat but you're still
not even thinking that the boat's from
land
you know so we don't know the universe
has all that you know fair fair point
i just think that like when i think of
humans becoming too powerful
that's a concept that i can kind of
grasp when i
see the way
you know just consider the way we've
paved over the world we've like you know
environmental destruct you know like i
feel like
we've kind of become too powerful yeah i
think you know i don't think anyone can
disagree that like we're like destroying
the planet and destroying each other
which is like we have the technology to
do that before we have the spirituality
to not do that you know right it's like
we this idea that
you know but this is the other thing the
universe to me
looks to be what we call duality
where every particle has a counterpart
so every every atom has like a negative
and a positive particle the realm of the
relative and well you have light you
have dark you have opposites you have
the past in the future all everything is
like duality
so even when you look at earth there's a
dual system you have democracy and
freedom and free will and then you have
authoritarianism and controlled and
absence of love absence of individuality
and it's competing systems but i think
it's representative of the universe we
live in you got to think of the yin and
the yang symbol that's like very real
that's to do that's duality every
ancient religion talked of duality we
have heaven and hell the mayans had the
two-faced god or whatever the gnostics
have the exact same thing where you have
you know varying versions of
a supreme loving kind of realm and
something that's opposite that's entropy
and falling apart and i think that like
i think we're just stuck in the middle
of it you know it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude